[Musik]
der hass knigge verhaltensregeln prüfen
das auffällige geht ganz schnell mit der
afg im bundestag muss man umgehen wie
ein verdammter erwachsener souverän und
gelassen natürlich jetzt den nur um
selbstinszenierung und sogar die adligen
in der afg benehmen sich wie
berufsschüler am ballermann
die von stock mal meiner hat kann reden
und hier beschwert sie sich
wahrscheinlich über den geruch des opas
vorher 709 abgeordnete müssen sich jetzt
mit schwachsinn cfd themen rumschlagen
wie sollte deutsch landessprache werden
ich finde nein ich bin allerdings
entschieden dafür dass der bundesadler
durch einen rauhaardackel ersetzt wird
ja auch das ist deutschland die sind
gewählt also nicht provozieren lassen
sondern die luft punkten inhaltlich
zerpflücken hier ein zwölfjähriger cdu
mann nachts vor der nicht mal das
gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
dienstes gelesen wo drinsteht dass ihr
entwurf für verfassungswidrig ist also
völliger unsinn jetzt so zu
argumentieren machen sie lieber ihre
arbeit richtig und hören sie mir mal zu
dann können sie nämlich noch was lernen
über die verfassung absitzt eilert
sobald er volljährig ist wähle ich den
wer austeilt muss auch einstecken als
cem özdemir neulich über rassisten in
der afg geredet hat konnte der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer seine
tränen kaum zurückhalten
das ist ein radikalismus im bundestag
der muss ein ende haben
und das hat özdemir beim letzten mal
gemacht uns als rassisten bezeichnet
somit bleiben die afg beklagt sich über
radikalismus im bundestag
folglich humor einfach der beste live fd
gucken burg hin oder her ihr habt immer
noch einen fraktionsvorsitzenden der
sich nie entschuldigt hat für die
geplante entsorgung einer
spd-politikerin in anatolien hätte ist
auch immer noch an bord stichwort
afrikanische ausbreitung typ
kurz gesagt die afd ist eine partei für
rassisten und für leuten den kein
problem haben mit rassisten in einer
partei zu sein
und ja ich sage gerade sehr oft das wort
rassisten was ihr mir verraten hat dass
euch das will tut wenn man euch
rassisten entrust ist eigentlich schon
erwähnt dass die rassisten
kassel
[Musik]
[Applaus]